hi guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's what I eat in a
day youtuber review is sponsored by
function of beauty and I'm going to be
reviewing Derek's submit of submit
nutrition now before we do I want to
tell you about this awesome new haircare
line I've been using from function of
beauty now I have always been pretty
picky about any beauty products that I
use especially now that I'm pregnant
and I love that this line has no
parabens or sulfates and is a hundred
percent vegan and cruelty free so this
is really simple you basically just fill
out a two-minute quiz about your hair
type your hair goals and any personal
preferences that you have and you also
get to choose your color and fragrance
they even print your name on the bottle
I mean how cute is this so as a blog my
hair does tend to go a little bit brassy
if I wash it too much so that was a
priority for me I also was looking to
fix split ends strengthen volumize and
add shine so they sent me they're
specially formulated purple shampoo plus
a daily conditioner and a leave-in
treatment for added moisture I also
opted for the peach scent and I have to
tell you like my hair smells really
really good it's also got some nice
shine and some strength even after
coloring so I'm really happy with the
results they also have a hair mask and
serum and everything is customized and
can be added on to any order if you're
looking for a new haircare product that
uniquely fits your needs check out the
link in my bio to get 20% off your first
order also a big reminder that this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only and it's not
meant to diagnose or prescribe any way
of eating so you should always speak to
a registered dietician and doctor about
your specific needs
ok so folks a little background on
Derrick now Derrick is a plant-based
certified nutritional practitioner who's
graduated from the Institute of holistic
nutrition now because this is a question
that has come up a lot before I do want
to quickly clarify the difference
between a nutritionist and a registered
dietitian so a dietitian is a regulated
nutrition professional that has gone
through extensive university education
and training and nutritional sciences a
nutritionist can really be anyone
this is not a regulated term but
somebody who identifies as a
nutritionist could be your next-door
neighbor with no nutrition education or
it could be somebody with a PhD in
nutrition sciences there are some great
comprehensive nutrition programs and
there are ones that you could easily
complete on a weekend online so really
it's like comparing apples to oranges so
obviously there are great discrepancies
here there are amazing nutritionists and
there are sketchy ones so just a heads
up that if you see somebody use this
title it's best to ask a little bit more
about their credentials and education
first now in contrast you cannot call
yourself a registered dietician unless
you've completed a minimum of a four
year undergrad in nutritional sciences a
two year combined master's degree or a
one year internship then you have to
pass the National Board Exam and in a
lot of cases you need annual continuing
education credits to keep yourself up to
date
you're also regulated by a college to
ensure that we you know maintain our
oath to do no harm
now nutritionist is not a regulated term
so if you run into a problem with
malpractice or poor advice there's
really little that you can do about it
and there's very little preventing that
person from giving that advice that is
why you may see some not-so-great
nutritionists talk about really sketchy
unproven miracle supplements or diets
and you won't see that same enthusiasm
necessarily from registered dietitians
and it's because we are really committed
to evidence-based practice having said
that there are lots of amazing awesome
evidence-based nutritionists and
holistic practitioners out there who are
not registered dietitians but like I
said you definitely need to do your
research and personally I know there
seems to be a lot of professional
competition between these two parties
but I actually see a lot of value from
learning from one another and actually
working collaboratively as a bit of a
team so like I said I'm not bashing
nutritionists there are amazing
nutritionists out there giving amazing
advice but it is something that you need
to of course do your research on so on
that note let's dive in with Derek's
first breakfast
so it's about mid-morning now and I
haven't had anything to eat today I
usually like to try and come to my
workouts fast if I can and sometimes I
work out too late in the day where it's
not possible but today is one of those
days where I can so I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be a good workout I always feel so
good when I work out fairly early in the
day and fasted now in terms of
exercising fasted or not there is some
research to support fasting for improved
aerobic performance so the idea is that
since your fasted you'll have lower
levels of stored carbohydrates aka
glycogen so they will deplete rather
quickly and as a result you may use more
fat to fuel your exercise now keep in
mind that this is not for everyone and
often it really only works for people if
they're exercising early in the morning
so that they're not starving by the time
that they work out you know having a
little bit of fuel in the tank can often
give you the energy that you need to get
you through a hard session so always
listen to your body and find a routine
that ultimately works best for you but
it seems like this is working for for
Derek so amazing now of course if you
have certain medical conditions like
diabetes then it is extremely important
that you speak to your doctor before
trying fasted exercise let's see what
else he has to say
[Music]
okay so there's nothing really wrong
with taking beetroot crystals before a
workout but like he said you definitely
do not need it there is some research
that has shown that the nitric oxide in
beetroot may increase vo2 max also time
to exhaustion improve blood pressure and
overall oxygen delivery to the muscles
however the research is definitely mixed
in this area and we really do need more
information specifically around dose and
overall impact that you can stand on so
I've got some pumpkin seeds that are
going on there as well
[Music]
okay so this looks incredible I mean I
love that he added banana and dates to
his oatmeal to sweeten it naturally
without added sugar while providing that
slow burning energy and the smoothie
brings a nice helping of veggies with
the kale some healthy fats from the flax
and protein with the protein powder he
did make an interesting comment however
about tumeric and led that I definitely
want to address but first let's hear
what he has to say okay so there is some
research that has shown that tumeric
produced in certain countries mainly
India and Bangladesh contain higher
levels of lead chromate which is an
additive used to enhance its yellow
color using fresh tumeric is ultimately
a really great idea to avoid this
altogether like he said but you can also
look for turmeric source from elsewhere
if you want the convenience and are
concerned cheers to that Derrick I love
that you are calling that out and if you
want to hear my personal thoughts on
food combining we've got two videos here
that I'm gonna link to but Derrick thank
you for fighting the good fight with me
let's take a look at breakfast number
two okay so this is an example of
Derrick eating before a workout although
it is just simple sugars mainly from
fruit with a little bit of the protein
and the healthy fats from the hemp arts
this can actually be really helpful for
people who are sensitive to eating a lot
before a workout and it can give you
that fast digesting energy to fuel your
workout let's take a look at what he's
eating after exercising
smoothie bowl just kind of helped me to
slow down my eating so I don't just gulp
it all down really quickly and there's a
few things to chew in there so it helps
with the digestion as well so I just got
some fresh blueberries on there and this
granola here by Angie - I also have
already talked a lot about the idea
between eating a smoothie bowl and
drinking a smoothie through a straw when
I reviewed Mona Vance tips on how to
reduce bloating so if you haven't
already watched that video definitely
check it out right here
but yeah the smoothie Bowl looks super
delicious we've got lots of lots of
color we've got some protein from the
protein powder we've got some healthy
fats and the flax that granola looks
amazing I would like to get my hands on
it as well and I definitely also agree I
like some little crunchy bits on top of
my smoothie Bowl as well so looks pretty
good I usually have so just one banana a
couple of frozen berries one pitted
medjool date I had a tablespoon and a
half or two tablespoons of ground
flaxseed in there as well so this is a
great tip for those you who maybe
struggle and you're eating for the day
if you're not sure how busy your day is
gonna be or or you aren't sure when
you're gonna be able to eat next
I do recommend having a small meal or a
snack before you leave the house to just
tide you over otherwise I do find that
we tend to get ravenously hungry and
this is typically when less mindful food
decisions get made
but again looks like a very balanced
smoothie we've got protein we've got
lots of fruit we've got some veggies in
there too
looks delicious so let me know give you
my overall thoughts on breakfast in
general I think that Derick is doing a
great job of getting in some healthy
fruits veggies fat and protein probably
my only criticism here is that I'd love
to see some more non drinkable
breakfasts though I get that it's a
total convenience thing and he's
especially is like a pre or post-workout
so if it works for him it works for me
let's move on to lunch
some hummus some tofu the smoked oppa
this stuff is so good and then avocado
just on some toast so so we get this
bread it's like super fresh and it is so
so tasty and you can see it's just like
really really clean ingredients nothing
too crazy added to it oh so I also went
and put some kimchi on top of it and
then some pea shoots as well and also
some hot sauce that looks so so good
okay
so here he's got a great source of
complex carbohydrates from the bread
we've got some plant-based protein from
the smoked tofu and a little from the
hummus and of course some healthy fats
from the avocado and I also loved the
kimchi on top and the naturally
fermented bread I mean these are all
really great for god help so yes please
oh my gosh
I am always down for tacos and I love
that more restaurants are offering vegan
options without necessarily completely
getting rid of some animal-based options
either you know I just feel like it
allows flexibility and that way
everybody can find something that they
like now he didn't mention what protein
he has on his tacos but it looks like
one has tofu and maybe other has like
vegan chicken there may be some black
beans on the other one but I can't
really say for sure either way so great
to see that he's making sure that he's
getting adequate protein from a variety
of sources also tacos are so great
because you get lots of veggies in there
you get your protein you get your
healthy fats and the guac and your carbs
in the tortilla so basically a perfectly
balanced meal and I am totally craving
Mexican right now I'm quarantined I
gotta make my own damn tacos let's take
a look at lunch three green chopped kale
lentils sweet potato tahini avocado
watermelon radish these things are so
cool any of these look also cucumber
pickled shallots shaved carrots pepitas
and seasoned
my kind of woman so we also got some
almond butter on toast the almond butter
local berry preserves coconut yogurt oh
my gosh that is a super yummy looking
bowl and I love that he's got some
lentils in there for plant-based protein
we got sweet potato and rice for our
complex carbs as well as from the
lentils and then we've got a variety of
beautiful colorful veggies I also
noticed that he pays attention to making
sure he gets a variety of colors in
which of course helps to make sure that
you're getting a variety of nutrients
also that almond butter toast looks like
a great idea just to sneak in some extra
protein and healthy fats and also it
like looks so delicious let's talk about
my overall thoughts on lunch I am
definitely a fan of Derek's lunches here
I mean he's not afraid to try different
foods and eat meals that will keep him
full for hours I actually find his
lunches to be really well-rounded and
just generally super delicious looking
and meats it makes vegan food so so
appealing I also love that he's getting
a variety of fats from the hemp seeds of
tahini and avocado and he makes sure to
mix it up in terms of protein by using
tofu beans lentils and meat alternatives
so great so tasty let's move on to
dinner I'm probably gonna make a stir
fry it's pretty much what I make like
five nights out of the week it's just so
easy to make it so quick you can use up
like leftovers really easily which I
have here and yeah it's really easy to
put like a whole bunch of healthy stuff
into and to make it tasty so it's really
nothing to lose there so I've got this
pot of rice and lentils which I cooked
up last night and some veggie broth so
I'm gonna put that on the stove and heat
that up and I just added some more
veggie broth to it because the rice
looked kind of dry
so dinner's looking all right we got
some carbs from the rice there's a
little bit of protein in the lentils
that are in there but not a whole lot
and then all the nutrients from all the
veggies but we definitely need to add
some more protein to this all right so
you can always count on a can of black
beans for some good protein one thing
that I like to do to make really tasty
sauces or at least give me like a
starting point when I'm making sauces is
to hit on three different flavors and
those flavors are sweet salty and tangy
so for sweet today we're using a pitted
medjool date for the salty component I'm
going to be using some tamari and then
for tangy today I'm gonna be using this
apple cider vinegar we've got some nice
tahini here some Lebanese tahini some
grainy mustard this really helps the
fats and the water that we're gonna be
adding to this kind of emulsified you
get a little bit everything in here
really good wow that looks like a really
satisfying meal and I love that it's
really so colorful and it's a ton of
different nutrient-dense foods in it
there is a lot of good stuff going on so
we've got loads of veggies plus carbs
from a rice we've got protein the
lentils and beans and healthy fats with
the tahini sauce and avocado I mean a
stir-fry like this is such a great way
to use up extra ingredients like he
talked about I will just say that I
noticed he doesn't seem to cook with oil
which is becoming a theme with a lot of
whole food vegans that I refuse so so if
you're interested in my thoughts in the
no oil trend definitely check out this
video right here that I just recently
posted on my youtube channel now I also
want to flag that if you're watching
this and you think that you've prepare
all of those veggies that every single
meal to be healthy that is not true
of course most people do not get enough
vegetables but there is a lot of prep
and going on here with all those
different vegetable components so I just
want people to know that you don't have
to become a professional sous chef
chopping up vegetables all day long to
have a balanced diet I mean I'm so glad
that this works for Derek but I totally
acknowledge that for most of us myself
included as a busy mom preneur that it's
just not realistic to have to cut up
all of those vegetables for every single
meal let's take a look at meal 2 and
it's basically like a fermented
fermented soybean it's good yeah it's a
great source of vitamin k2 it's like
highest source of vitamin k2 the plant
kingdom again totally it's solid looking
bowl here and while I find a lot of
these youtubers bowls very large in size
but lacking in substance this guy seems
to know how to build a better bowl we've
got loads of colorful vegetables protein
from the tofu and leftover tempeh a
little fat from the tahini some
slow-burning carbs from the whole grains
lots of good stuff again there are a lot
of veggies to have to prepare which
probably feels not so realistic for most
people
plus the no oil theme is definitely
alive and well but I will like I said
you need to watch the whole video to
watch me unpack that I also want to talk
about natto which while slimy is really
nutritious particularly a great source
of vitamin K like he said now there are
actually two main types of vitamin K k1
and k2 vitamin k1 is found in
plant-based foods like leafy green
vegetables Brussels sprouts broccoli and
spinach it's the main source of vitamin
K in the diet but vitamin k2 is actually
usually microbial source meaning it
comes from products that utilize
different bacteria for production like
cheese or yogurt or in this case natto
which is what Derek is trying out here
so briefly it's also found certain
animal products and is produced by our
gut bacteria now both are great to get
into the diet and I am happy to see
Derek show his viewers of food that is
maybe not so well known let's see how it
tastes
it stretches for I am not surprised they
didn't love it I mean I think with a lot
of these strongly flavored foods like
natto it may be best to incorporate it
with other flavors and maybe not right
off the spoon but also the slime factor
yeah that would put me off too so
totally get that it was not a hit with
his buddies okay let's close things off
with meal three tofu and with some
veggies and hash browns as well so for
the scrambled tofu basically I'm gonna
do is get about half of this huge chunk
of tofu crumble it up and I'm just gonna
add some seasoning so usually I would
use you know like turmeric and onion
powder garlic powder and a few things
but I don't have all those here in this
kitchen because it's not my home so I'm
gonna be using this I just got this from
Trader Joe's the other day and so when
they recommended it and it's just like a
sort of you can see the vegan chicken
list seasoning all right so there is
breakfast for dinner
I also added oh geez it's all about good
fine fine you call it I also added bagel
this is like everything bagel from
Trader Joe's saw these the other day and
they were they smelled so good they were
so cheap so I had to have it so I put
some greens on the plate and then I
added the stir-fry with the lentils and
their room and ESCO broccoli and
everything on there and then just some
of that tahini sauce that I made I love
breakfast for dinner and unlike a lot of
people's breakfasts Derick has made a
point to ensure that there's actually a
lot of vegetables in his dinner version
so I like that I'm seeing
carbs here of course what's up potatoes
and the bagel we've got protein with the
tofu and the lentils lots of fiber rich
veggies and some fat with a teeny
dressing not a lot of fat again since he
doesn't cook with oil so it doesn't
surprise me that his carb portions need
to be as large as they are to help him
feel satisfied so so if he wanted to cut
back on portions and not have to eat so
much but still feel satiated he may want
to just add a little bit more fat in his
cooking or if
it's not for him maybe throw some
avocado in there or a little bit more of
those healthy fats from nuts seeds
things like that okay let's talk about
my overall thoughts on dinner generally
speaking Dericks meals have a lot of
variety and good nutrition I love how he
incorporates different colorful veggies
into his dishes shows us that you can be
using plant-based proteins in a variety
of different ways and makes cooking more
of like a dump it and don't worry about
it exercise than having to follow a
recipe to a tee
I get that the whole stir fry thing may
be a little bit repetitive for people
but at least he's getting in a variety
of vegetables protein sources and carbs
in his dinners and it's also a great way
to use up any leftovers now let's talk
about Derek's overall nutrition number
one are his meals balanced well based on
his most recent 180 days I would
definitely say that his meals are
relatively balanced and nutrient-dense
on average he's getting about 2680
calories per day 60% of which is from
carbs 24% from fat and 16% from protein
although these do fit within the
recommended macronutrient distribution
and he seems to be doing great with them
others who are working out at this level
may potentially benefit from a little
bit more protein I also find some of his
meals to be a little bit repetitive but
he does try to use different ingredients
even though may be the type of meal is
similar so I am ultimately totally cool
with that
also I'm nitpicking but his interests do
seem to be a little bit large in
comparison with the rest of the day
which doesn't necessarily make the most
sense for most people considering his
training is happening usually earlier on
so if he's feeling really really hungry
by dinner and meaning to have that huge
meal to kind of satisfy him for the day
it might be a good idea to add a little
bit more fat to his cooking or boost up
the protein to evening meal to increase
the satiety factor without adding so
much bulk now is Derek missing out on
any major in nutrients in his diet well
Derek is vegan and therefore avoids any
kind of animal products with that being
said Derek is doing an excellent job
making sure that he's still getting in
adequate nutrition from a variety of
foods he's getting a nice variety of
protein from tofu almond butter not
seeds lentils beans meat alternatives
and plan
based protein powder he's definitely
getting in more than enough fiber from
whole grains vegetables pulses rice
fruit etc I mean this is actually a very
high fiber diet for most people it may
be too high and very likely to cause
digestive issues but if this is the way
he's kind of used to eating it's also
very possible that his gut has adjusted
to the excess of load
now although Derrick is getting enough
fat from his diet technically I would
encourage him to try to get a better
variety of fats into his diet besides
relying on just a few fat rich foods
like tahini for example he could add a
little bit of oil to salads or
stir-fries eat other fat rich foods like
olives and other nuts and seeds maybe
throw in some more avocado etc again I
am just reviewing three days of his diet
so he may be eating these things on
other days but we do know that the best
thing we can do with the fat in our diet
is to get a variety of fat since each
oil and fat provides a unique fatty acid
profile and we really want to try to hit
all of the fats that we can now all this
meals are packed with colorful fruits
and vegetables provide amazing
antioxidants and nutrients so I'm not
really concerned about micronutrients
he didn't actually mention taking any
supplements in these videos which you
know I do prefer influencers to
regularly disclose but in addition to of
course b12 he may also benefit from a
vegan omega-3 supplement with DHA yes I
acknowledge that he's getting omega
threes from the flaxseed and the heme
parts that he consumes but these foods
contain ala which is not as well
utilized by the body some ala does get
converted into EPA and DHA but
admittedly in small amounts so therefore
a supplement may actually be really
beneficial now are there any problematic
claims or assumptions on his channel for
the most part I'm very happy with
Derek's videos and the lifestyle that he
promotes I will say he does use the word
clean to describe ingredients and I
think it's best to like steer clear of
that type of wording and verbiage if we
can also like I mentioned I notice he
doesn't use any oil while he's cooking
and he actually has a whole entire video
discussing this vlog
according to Derek he doesn't use any
oil in his cooking because he chooses to
avoid processed oils and his rationale
is really because process oils are very
calorically dense but lack nutrition
therefore he prefers to get his fats
from foods that give him a wide range of
nutrients now I can definitely agree
that oils are very calorie dense meaning
you get a lot of calories in a small
serving however this does not
necessarily mean that they're devoid of
nutrition so for example one tablespoon
of olive oil provides 13% and 7% of your
daily vitamin E and K needs respectively
as well they do facilitate the
absorption of fat soluble vitamins and
yes of course eating whole foods that
are high in fat can also help with this
but to vilify oil and make a blanket
statement that all oils are bad just
it's not fair or true there are
definitely oils that are overly
processed without a doubt but opting for
healthier oil like cold-pressed extra
virgin olive oil is totally completely
fine in moderation again and you can of
course be mindful of serving sizes I'm
not telling you to go drink a bottle of
olive oil but we don't necessarily need
to demonize it or eliminate it either so
while I can totally respect that Derek
chooses to get his fast from a whole
food diet there's no reason not to
include a little bit of oil and
personally I just think this is an
overly restrictive food rule that can
interfere with a lot of social aspects
of eating and food besides that it is
clear to me that Derek makes sure to
avoid making any substantial nutrition
claims and really focuses his time on
sharing delicious vegan meals and
recipes that fuel his body to me I think
that Derek very much like shows like
game-changers is really great evidence
that you can 100% be vegan and maintain
and build muscle so kudos to that so I
just want to finish off mentioning some
of my favorite takeaways from Derek's
channel number one lots of delicious
easy and balanced recipes while the
veggie chopping is probably too
cumbersome for most people at least his
recipes are simple to follow enough for
people at home number two he's a great
example that vegans can build muscle too
because I'm sure that you are all sick
of people asking you
hey where do you get your protein and
number three he doesn't seem to be pushy
about his vegan lifestyle or giving
nutrition advice bottom line I truly
enjoyed exploring Derek's Channel I'm
actually a huge fan of his positive
personality and approach to life and
it's really fun to watch more awesome
male youtubers in the Wellness space his
meals are simple to follow nutrient
dense and most importantly look really
delicious I am definitely a fan and I'm
gonna be watching a lot more for some
recipe inspiration well folks that is
all for today thanks again to function
and beauty for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it a thumbs
up leave me a comment below with who you
would like to see reviewed next
subscribe to my channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]